your mower blade needs to be sharp so
that you're getting a clean slice of the
leaf blade which then minimizes stress
to the plant the plant uses less water
but more importantly a dull blade
increases your fuel consumption twenty
to thirty percent so if you don't have
access to a workbench a small table will
work fine and your basic C clamp now
what I'm sharpening the blade won't move
around on me it will make it a lot
easier to keep the same edge one thing
you want to check for when you're
inspecting these blades are large dings
or major scratching pitting on the front
of the blade another thing to look for
when a blade is pretty much on its last
legs
you'll have a crack starting to form
right here when that happens that means
you have a compromised blade it's beyond
the point of sharpening it you should
replace it so nothing bad happens I like
to use two hands when I'm using a file
not to apply pressure you're not using a
lot of pressure when you're operating
file you're just letting the tool do its
work you're just guiding it along you'll
notice that I'm really not pushing this
down at all other than to keep it flat
on the blade this is a single edge file
meaning it only has grooves in one
direction so you can only move in one
direction which is always away from you
one thing you want to stay away from is
rolling your hands when you're running a
file you're going to round the edge of
this blade and that's not gonna do you
any good it's probably gonna make it
worse so try to stay keep it flat if you
have major dings in the blade on the
front edge it may not be a wasted blade
you can still use it but you are gonna
want to file that edge down I like to
wear gloves just in case I slide off
when I'm filing that I don't cut myself
you'll notice that I'm always moving
away from me so this is a small balance
it's under $10 it's something you can
find at your basic hardware store lawn
and garden stores so we have our
mounting hole your center screw that
holds the plate in place we also use
this hole to set on top of the balancer
the balancer has ridges on it to
accommodate for multiple sizes of main
Center holes so we've actually lightened
up this side we haven't lightened up
this side yet if it's not balanced it's
gonna wobble when it spins that's gonna
add to wear and tear to your blades it's
also gonna add to streaking and your
cutting it's going to give you an uneven
cut when your blades aren't balanced
properly if the blade comes out of
balance where you take more metal off of
one end than the other that can also
affect fuel consumption and the quality
of cut you're going to get as well when
you're putting them back in you can
essentially tighten it up by hand almost
90% of the way try not to over tighten
it because you got to get it off at some
point